a Labour Party rally it looks familiar
and it sounds familiar to you guys we're
gonna have to think of a new song you
know no pressure Rebecca long Bailey's
pitch she's more than Corbin 2.0
left-wing radicalism with the northern
and female edge a promise to abolish the
Lord's and replace it with a senate
outside london we will put power back
where it belongs in your hands the last
choice which she knows she needs to put
some clear red water between herself and
mr. Corbin after that crushing election
defeat because he was a kind honorable
decent human being he was different from
any politician that we'd ever seen but
we lost the general election and we have
to recognize that we do need to change
not too much though changing leader does
not mean changing course Rebecca long
Bailey's radical left-wing politics and
no longer on the fringe of the Labor
Party they are now the mainstream and
she is the flagbearer [ __ ] Jeremy Corbyn
but can she carry his momentum through
this campaign all who members decide
that they need a leader who perhaps has
a better chance of winning the argument
outside the party that leader could be
carest Armour another frontrunner who
could claim the center ground what I
want to do is to rebuild our party and
be in a position to win an election so
that change can actually happen an
outsider in this contest at least and we
formed we trying to sell herself as the
battle-hardened candidate tough enough
to take on Boris Johnson we must not
make the mistake of defining it as a
choice between who's gonna take us to
the left or who's gonna take us to the
right or who's gonna take us to the
center because the only issue the only
issue that really matters now is who is
gonna take us forward Rebecca long
bailey has won this room but of course
mr. Corbin could do this too
our challenge is to prove to members
shattered from four successive election
defeats that she can win where mr.
Coburn could not bath Rick be Sky News
Manchester